in the port of dejin fishing boats
return from increasingly Troubled Waters
close to the border between North and
South there's been a recent rise in
artillery firing drills out to sea by
North Korea people here are reluctant to
talk about the dangers but like this
fisherman admit they're concerned about
the impact on their livelihoods
these women say they could hear the
shelling
when I heard the artillery shells I was
wondering if a war was about to break
out
life becomes difficult if North Korea
keeps firing artillery how can the fish
survive
the drills have been in protest against
a return this year to joint military
exercises between South Korean and U.S
forces
its divided opinion here with this
demonstration in Seoul by Japanese and
South Korean religious and Civic groups
warning the saber rattling could lead to
a wider confrontation
now the Korean Peninsula is becoming a
powder keg for a new cold war that could
expand to a confrontation between China
and America
last week North Korea fired an
intercontinental ballistic missile and
dozens of short-range weapons one of
which has been recovered one of the
missiles Flew Over the de facto Maritime
border Landing in the Seas close to
South Korea's territorial Waters the
first time that's happened since the
peninsula was partitioned and further
raising tension levels on it as a
precaution fishing boats were told to
return to Port the Navy and the Coast
Guard
urgently asked us to stop fishing and
some boats had to abandon their Nets in
a sign of increasing brinksmanship South
Korean fighter jets responded by firing
missiles of their own across the
dividing line
this corner of South Korea had hopes of
benefiting from the friendlier relations
of recent years as it straddles one of
the main roads for inter-korean
exchanges that road like chances of
reconciliation seemingly not heading
anywhere
Rob McBride Al Jazeera goes on County
South Korea